can Tom Cruise fly a plane yes
yes I fly airplanes I'm a multi-engine
instrument rated commercial pilot Doug
and I are both aviators so we both love
to fly tent top Crews hold his breath
for six minutes
yes I can hold my breath for six minutes
uh you were there when I was doing it
you were in the tank and leaves it in
London you'd swim back and forth in the
bottom of the tank like four or five
laps that was wild and I'd be up on the
surface with goggles watching him I
wasn't even working on the movie I just
wanted to watch Tom Cruise hold his
breath for six minutes can Tom Cruise
fly a helicopter yes uh again I fly a
helicopter I fly aerobatics in that and
commercially rated helicopter Pilots I
was in a helicopter with you the first
time you were really learning to fly
yeah yeah that was that was a you've
come a long way since I've been trained
very hard